[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody yeah we survived sunday
yeah last night yeah you were yeah
that's okay though i said [ __ ] it i just
got them left
i said all right jay didn't want to end
it she just kept going and i'm like okay
it's in the show so i just
got up says i'm going yeah he's so
cranky
yeah i'm gonna make a whole series of
shirts with your little face just going
like like that and then it'll just say
i'm
i'm getting fussy or i'm getting cranky
or [ __ ] this [ __ ] or something like that
because you're just like you never want
to do anything
no i mean the show what did was pretty
long last night it came out like four
yeah four and a half hours four hours
and 45 minutes
didn't really seem like it's that long
at the time that's what i mean it's like
that's
it's weird because when we first start
when we first start doing the shows
i guess alcohol like kind of like makes
time more malleable because
when we first start doing the show it
seems like i was like oh my god we've
only been on for half an hour we've only
been on for an hour
but then by the time we get up to three
four hours i'm like whoa
oh my god that's like you know what i
mean i remember we tried to
i could go we started we tried to
condense the show into one hour
i can't i still can't believe we did
that for such a long time i'm like how
did we do that
we must have just never got off on
anything solid packed
information or if we did go offline i
took it out
you were ended up being wikipedia
basically yeah
i guess like some of the shows turned
out being funny but yeah
you know i mean like i said the
necrophilia one like we were talking
about last night you know at that time
that's what a lot of people were doing
it wasn't free form and it wasn't
like long form and it wasn't uh
it wasn't live streaming trail
there wasn't any money in live stream
there wasn't live streaming
yeah i mean but you make more money live
streaming
than you do just post videos yeah with
ad revenue
right there is ad revenue but well i
think the nice thing too about live
streaming is that
yeah you live stream but then at the end
of it you have a video
too and then you get it then you get
yeah then you get ad revenue off the
video
tila said we watched phantom of the
paradise last night yeah blast with it
yeah what'd you think of that it's yeah
that's a fun movie i think yeah
i like rocky horror better but did you
notice the link between
uh phantom of the paradise and rudy
raymore i bet you didn't
because you don't know about guns that
was the same damn [ __ ] gun that rudy
ray was using
and used in his movies that the phantom
of the paradise used
okay it was a locally produced
california it was
that was california's response to the
[ __ ]
uzi i'm glad you're excited yeah
yeah i was such an [ __ ] i think it
was like something called
like a high standard or something it was
it was kind of a
something or other seeing machine i
don't remember the name of that thing
i don't know whatever it was something
that only showed up in movies every now
and then
yeah it's well made but just some
locally produced california thing
okay so cnc machine or something
let's talk about the ripper yeah
this is a new series that netflix just
added
i guess they edited a few weeks ago
because i had a couple people a couple
of y'all
like contacted me and said you know are
you guys going to review it and i said
of course i'm going to review it because
we did a show about the yorkshire ripper
and it's kind of a case that um
i was always really interested and i
even read a couple books about it like
way back in the day i think when i was
living over there
because you know because i you know
i lived there and it was like i kind of
got into a thing where i was into a lot
of british crime
so this um it
this actually turned out being a really
interesting it's weird because though
even though we did a
show about the case before you comple
you had completely forgotten about
any and all details of the crime because
you were like watching it it's only four
episodes or four episodes or like 40 47
minutes started jumping out
at me yeah i think like you kind of
remember but you didn't remember like
what peter sutcliffe looked like
you didn't remember that he had been
caught you don't remember like any of
that stuff
i just remembered i remembered the case
in the situation that was some that was
some uh
uk stuff so yeah and i didn't find out
about that case until you know in recent
times you know had i grown up with that
case of course i would remember it
i think we did i don't know if we did
like a whole show dedicated to him but i
think we did a show that was him and
like
one other like maybe dennis nilsson or
somebody like that
um you know but yeah this was a case
that i'm
actually that i was actually pretty
familiar with but one thing that i
thought was really cool about
this docu-series
was that one thing i liked is that they
did it in chronological order
um you know so they didn't like jump
around and stuff i also liked
that it was a lot more focused on the
victims and on the investigation
and not so much on peter sutcliffe they
didn't even
show a picture of peter sutcliffe or
like talk about him until the last
episode like what they talked about him
when he got caught
but they didn't really talk about him
like prior to that because
in the universe of the docu-series they
didn't know who he was
you look like count dante yeah i think i
think he said that last night on the
show that he had like the big
more of a [ __ ] version to count dante
though skinnier
yeah yeah i think the thing about this
like one of the most famous things about
the case was that
um there were a lot of uh
false leads that led to the cops
like not catching this dude because the
cops i mean they
they only caught him like just because
of this crazy lucky
fluke because this was like a four or
five year period
right like 1975 to 1980 and he ended up
killing like 13 women
and they found out later that he had
attacked some prior to that too that
didn't die but they didn't really know
you know they weren't really looking for
a serial killer at that point
but i do feel like they did like talk to
a bunch of they they talked to a bunch
of um
victims that survived they talked to a
bunch of uh
people that had worked on the case they
talked to like a bunch of reporters that
had covered the case
so they really got a good um you know
selection of like people that were
involved in the [ __ ]
and as much as i don't want to i don't
remember how much we went into this when
we did a show about it but i don't
really want to like [ __ ] on the cops
because i know they were kind of like
trying to do their best
at the time but i kind of feel like one
of the things that
failed them in this particular
investigation was that
one they had a perception
which may have been a misperception that
this was a
prostitute killer and i mean as soon as
the first couple of
victims you know as far as as soon as
the first couple people had
women had been killed i think they kind
of like focused on prostitute killer
and then they just kind of like ran with
that
which in a way kind of like [ __ ] on the
victims a little bit because some of
them they weren't entirely sure if they
were prostitutes and also
when they kind of released it to the
media it seemed like the public was just
kind of like what
i'm not a prostitute so i'm all right um
even though they found out later which
is something that i didn't know and they
went into a little bit on this
was that a couple women i think it was
three women had been attacked
prior to the first victim dying it was
wilma mccann
and they all lived but they didn't hit
the same thing that's you know could he
because that was his ammo he would like
come up behind you and he'd like hit you
with a hammer
and then he would drag you somewhere and
stab you um
so three women had been attacked like
that in the area and
none of those three women were
prostitutes so i do kind of feel like
and the weird thing was the cops didn't
believe him yeah and it's like
like i said no one had been murdered at
that point because you know that was
early but it's like you know hey
some jackal like came up behind me and
like hit me in the [ __ ] head with a
hammer and like they had to go to the
hospital and [ __ ] like that it wasn't
like it was just some little
whatever so they almost kind of like
blew it off
yeah and i feel like there was a lot of
sort of victim blaming like i said
because they're like well
you know why were you out at night you
know what i mean the kind of thing like
why are you walking around the streets
at night
and [ __ ] like that like you shouldn't be
doing that um
you know so you like deserve it so there
was that kind of i think you might be
reading into it well no
but they it's weird because i think the
cops were powerless
to do anything about it was part of the
problem
uh because remember they said that the
[ __ ] uh the uh the police
were in a total shambles because they
weren't even really sure who was in
charge
of the damn police force yeah remember
yeah they had all kinds of
organizational problems
yeah it was like city county right so
i think it was more of a thing where the
where the law enforcement really
lacked coordination at that particular
time it had to do with a bunch of
reorganizations
um they reorganized the police force and
they moved
dudes that knew the beat well out out
into the
in into the larger area a larger area
they were trying to take all these
little parts of town and
and kind of homogenize it into one force
to cover a large area
and when they did that they they lost
the local
the they lost to the uh the all the
local talent
in other words the dudes that knew
exactly where they were they knew who
all the crooks were
knew all the hookers were you know what
i mean those guys are ended up
moving to a new yeah like a few miles
away and like not so it was kind of like
blind it had kind of like blinded the
police force and that was the first
thing that
that went down you know having worked in
organizations you know like military and
law enforcement type
organizations i know what that would do
and then there was something about the
chain of command what was it
the uh the there was something in in
what do you remember what the detail was
the chief of police was you couldn't
contact him
or they weren't sure who it was and it
was kind of like the
the force was running on autopilot like
a zom kind of like a zombie for a while
yeah until they realize that they did
that they did have a serial killer
on their hands then they they tried to
get their act together but it was too
late they were
they already had two women dead and like
three of them attacked and they didn't
want to count the first three for some
reason
they didn't really believe it they
didn't really believe it happened yeah
which was kind of strange that's a sign
of a
[ __ ] up police department when
because when she went to go report that
some dude hit her in the head with a
hammer they just looked at her like she
had two heads like huh
yeah no i can't that there's something
all right about that that couldn't have
it was like that couldn't have happened
or it was or it was like they didn't
take it that seriously they didn't know
what to do about it yeah
it could be that the organization had no
response to that
they just wrote it down probably yeah
you're hitting the head in the hammer
but you're alive then what are we going
to do about it
right we don't know who it was like you
might want to like find the person that
did that
would be you know a big priority i think
that's what it was it was a long time
ago he's gone we what are we gonna do
yeah i think it was like that
because the type of police that you were
talking about in that era
they were the kind of dudes that just
walked around and [ __ ] find people
and told people to [ __ ] leave the
area and uh
arrested some [ __ ] thugs or maybe
they'll tell some hooker to hit
to [ __ ] scram walk into the [ __ ]
bar and [ __ ] break up a fight and
we're like bouncers
you know and meter maids they're like
they were like a deal like that
yeah i don't think it was a serious i
don't think i'm
fighting you yeah they didn't really
seem equipped yeah
and the thing too is that they didn't
have a lot you know obviously they
didn't have a lot of the forensic [ __ ]
that they have nowadays it's like they
could do blood typing they could do that
kind of stuff but
everything had to be written down on
pieces of paper very famously they had
so much information so many leads and
stuff that they had written all these
index cards
that they had to have the floor of the
police station like
um what's the word that i'm looking for
they had
like the floor was going to collapse so
they had to have it like you know
fortified or whatever
yeah like because there was so much
[ __ ] paperwork that this [ __ ]
thing generated
but another um another kind of thing
that put them off the track
was the letters they like got all these
letters supposedly from
you know from the killer and that very
famous
tape which supposedly was from the
killer and i'm not
entirely sure why it seems like they
pretty much immediately
thought these two things are legit
which [ __ ] up the investigation like
big time especially that tape because
they thought that that was the real
killer talking
and they so they go to this big thing
and they're like they have this linguist
and he's like you know i narrowed it
down to this one village like one square
mile
and they went and like you know they
kind of like um
investigated all the people in that
village and [ __ ] like that you know
because of the dude's accent
but then it turned out when they caught
him and i mean very famously too peter
sutcliffe was interviewed by the cops
what like nine times
yeah and because he didn't have that
same accent he didn't sound like that so
well it's probably not him yeah there
there's british people making comments
in the comments section
but and i was kind of astounded because
they were interviewing one cop he was
talking about
that time and he's like yeah it was a
rough area they had a bunch of um
guys from like jamaica running around
and you know they'd smile at you and you
see gold teeth you know
they had gold teeth and boy you know you
didn't really want to mess with them
and i realized i was going like man
there's a big difference between british
cops and american cops
and i mean and i think the biggest
difference was is they just
ran around in pairs they didn't have
guns you know
well and i think that from an american
perspective that's not a cop
i mean cop shows up and kills you that's
what an american
well like i said show up you give any
[ __ ] they just shoot you
i think they too that they weren't real
familiar with
this with this area because there was
like such a lot of immigration in the
area
i also like too the way this um
documentary it kind of goes a lot more
into
what was going on at the time like all
the economic [ __ ] that was going on at
the time that maybe had spurred some of
these women like to have to go out and
be prostitutes because you know all this
you know industrial like the factories
had closed and like everyone was out of
work and stuff
so they you know they didn't go a huge
amount into it but they did give you
like a lot of background
and they had like a lot of um archival
footage from that time so you could see
like
how shitty like all of these kind of um
north of england like neighborhoods were
you know were in like a lot of more like
burned out buildings and [ __ ] like that
so they did kind of give you like a lot
of really good context
um but yeah i i do feel like this case
in particular i think sheila asked
wasn't this the first case solved by dna
i don't think it was this one um
[ __ ] and i feel like i know what case
that is but it's not this
they actually solved this one
accidentally
um he had killed 13 women i believe
and he was in a car
with a woman like in like an odd place
and i guess they assumed that oh that's
it's a dude with a prostitute so
they pulled the guy over they came up to
like check it out they ran the plates on
the car
and the plate and the car didn't match
and then one of the cops that was in the
car kind of looked at the driver and
he's like man that looks just like
that drawing of you know the attacker
because a couple of the um victims had
lived
and one of them actually did see his
face and
he's like that kind of looks like him
and he just had a feeling
so later on like he went back to the
spot because what ended up happening was
when he
you know questioned the the guy and the
woman that was in the car who was a
prostitute
um he was like uh i have to go pee or he
like he ran around the corner or
whatever
so that cop like went back later on and
went around the corner to where that guy
had run to pee
supposedly and he found like a hammer
and a knife and all this other kind of
[ __ ]
and so then they went and arrested him
and
basically as soon as they got him in
custody he he just confessed to
everything yeah
so he could have lawyered up and got out
of it he didn't want to though
i kind of feel like at that point um but
he was a big suspect they'd already had
football
nine times yeah yeah nine times i but
and i think it was mostly because
of that tape yeah because they were like
that's not what his voice sounds like
he's a local guy
because they were kind of operating on
the assumption that this guy wasn't
local because he had a different accent
so
the fact that a lot you know that some
of the cops like suspected him enough to
like keep bringing him in because his
name kept popping up
yeah and there was the whole thing too
about one of the women that was killed
they found like a five pound note like
in a little hidden pocket in her purse
and they think that peter sutcliffe
remembered like after he killed her and
left her he was like oh [ __ ]
that that note can probably be like
traced back to me
so he went back to the body and tried to
find it like he dumped the purse out but
he couldn't find it because it was in
like this little hidden pocket in the
purse
so they found it and they did actually
end up tracing that
to i think just three factories like it
had been given to somebody like in their
pay packet
so um that was another thing where they
actually went and
they interviewed like the guy that
worked um who was like peter sutcliffe's
supervisor or something
and it's like the cops kept coming and
like interviewing the dude they're like
at the place that they worked they
called him the ripper
because they thought it was so funny
that the cops kept coming and it's like
you know
and i don't know if they like actually
baby in the back of their mind thought
maybe he is the serial killer
but they're like they called him that at
work i think the cops were
joking about him being the ripper too
well the one guy they were talking to
was the guy that worked
i think it was his supervisor like at
the factory where he worked and
they said yeah we were calling him that
all right i thought the cops were
calling him that to uh
um kind of jokingly i think at least one
cop because they did cops didn't think
he did it but his name kept coming up
and from when i remember they were like
they thought
the dude was he was a [ __ ] and that
wasn't who they
they weren't imagining that guy being
the killer yeah
imagine somebody that looked like the
killer
evidently this dude he would never
suspect him he was just a quiet guy
you know yeah and seemingly normal
upbringing i mean he had a wife he had a
job
um you know he wasn't like but but like
i said i think that's
maybe maybe you know that's better now
but i do feel like when people are
looking for a serial killer i think you
still
expect him to look like an ogre or some
[ __ ] like that
you don't expect like just this weedy
normal looking dude
yeah that's just like hanging out with
you know here's
his wife and here's his job and [ __ ]
like that he'd go to the pub
women and talk to him but they kind of
lose interest in him because he wouldn't
he wouldn't talk much he was he was real
quiet
yeah nobody said he was like you know a
freak or anything but they said it was a
little weird because he was just real
quiet that was kind of like
the that was the only thing that people
said was strange about him
was that he was just real quiet and
didn't talk much which isn't really that
weird
he had some kind of weird fantasy going
on where he just wanted to hit women
with a hammer and stab him
yeah and he didn't he didn't even need
sex he had girlfriends
and he didn't rape them either i don't
think he just really got off
on hitting them and then like just
stabbing the [ __ ] out of him and just
leaving them and he liked to leave them
he'd go back and look at him too yeah
and he went back to some of the sites
too and like i think one of because i
think at least one of the victims i
can't remember which one but i think she
had like at least one of her breasts cut
off
yeah and i don't know if he did that at
the time or if he went back later and
did it
so he was actually kind of ballsy
because he would leave
the bodies like sometimes he would kill
them like kind of in a secret area but
then he would drag them out like closer
to the road or like lay them out in an
alley so that they would be found like
right away
and sometimes even after he had done
that like if the body wasn't found he
would go back and like drag it
to a place where it was more public like
more open because he really wanted them
to be found
so it's almost like he was making some
weird kind of statement but
i don't know if he ever said like what
that [ __ ] statement was
yeah and he just didn't he wasn't what
they expected i mean he was kind of
sharp dressed kind of a 70s style
he had his perm and his beard and his
little [ __ ]
bell bottoms in his suit [ __ ] suit
coat and his little [ __ ]
medallion like type [ __ ] you know just
like a typical
leisure suit 70s looking yeah like i
said you would never
think that and he was young and he
didn't even have the crazy eyes like
some of the serial killers have
no you got count dante to me you know
you can look them up
yeah it wasn't very big i don't think he
was very big guy
kind of skinny yeah he wasn't he wasn't
like real big or anything like that
well you know that's it's just so weird
to me and and i feel like a lot of
a lot of like kind of jack the ripper
type stuff was attributed to him
because when they were you know
investigating the case like before they
caught him
like i said they got those letters in
the mail and for some reason they just
assumed that they were from the killer
but they weren't
i don't know if they ever caught the
person that sent the letters
i know that they caught the person that
sent the tape i don't think it was the
same person necessarily
but the letters basically what the
person that wrote the letters did
was they took jack the ripper's letters
from back in the day
and then just kind of like rewrote them
but like plug different words in to make
it like relevant to
the yorkshire ripper case um but yeah
i'd have to look into that
they don't think they mentioned it on
the documentary like if they ever caught
i don't think they mentioned that they
caught the person that
um that did the tape either but i know i
can't remember what the dude's name was
but they did catch him like many years
later they found out who he was
and he was just some dude that thought
it would be funny
to like send a tape because there's
always one or two you know
that which is why i don't know it seemed
very naive
of the cops to automatically assume that
these letters in this tape had come from
the actual killer because i i don't know
man i feel like nine times out of ten
it's just some
chuckle [ __ ] like thinking it's a joke
you know what i mean
i don't maybe that's i'm just pulling
that statistic out of my ass
but it does seem like that's very very
common like especially like a really
high profile case like this that there's
always like
some show that's going to be like hey it
wouldn't be funny if i sent him a tape
saying i'm the killer
teel and hernandez are like trying to
compare him to other killers like
ted bundy and uh richard ramirez what
does he say richard
no no the green river killer yeah no he
wasn't really a guy like
um green river killer or ted bundy
he was not as outgoing as ted bundy
not as flashy um he was kind of like a
down low so
yeah he was a down low [ __ ] yeah
and he wasn't um
who who was what was the the name of the
guy who did the green river killer again
what was his name jerry ridgeway yeah
ridgeway ridgeway was a [ __ ] worm
guy who's a total maggot so he and this
guy wasn't like that either he
he was just kind of like a non-entity
that was one thing that always struck me
about
about peter sutcliffe because he just
seems like a very bland
land yeah individual little dude with a
[ __ ] perm and a beard
yeah i mean you went like i said you
wouldn't notice he was just kind of
quiet yeah he had like
he was normal yeah dressed like he
didn't normally talk much
he had a wife um yeah there was just
like nothing remarkable about him
lack of character that'd be a good way
to yeah it was just really
a lack of character one thing that i
thought was funny and i saw another
reviewer point this out too they went
into this a little bit on the thing but
um
because like i said they kind of talked
about a lot of the [ __ ] that was going
on like in the culture at the time
and they were talking about how when the
killings were kind of at their height
the cops were trying to like impose a
curfew
on women and like women were like surely
it would be better to impose a curfew on
men
since it's a man that's doing the [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean it's like
we're not killing people it's like why
can't we walk around
he was in a car with uh some black chick
what wasn't she black
went to black yeah yeah yeah she was she
was a prostitute he had picked her up
yeah and he was gonna kill her yeah
because he had all his stuff
the cops drove by and they saw they saw
him in the car together
like in a weird spot that was like
getting ready to [ __ ] you know
she he she probably thought she was
gonna give some head but
he was gonna [ __ ] kill her and um
they
saw that car and realized what they
realized that license plate didn't
belong on that car
well yeah they thought they're like oh
there's a dude with a prostitute so
they kind of like i don't know if they
pulled him over or they just saw him
like over where he wasn't supposed to be
so they ran the plate and the plate and
the cards didn't match yeah
and then like i said one of the cops
noticed that the driver
was peter sutcliffe looked like the
drawing looked like a drawing
because they looked like yeah yeah at
this point and actually if you see that
like the photo fit
that they did of him it's very very good
um
and that was like one woman because i
think one woman got attacked and she
lived
but her head like her head injury was so
bad that she couldn't remember like she
didn't remember anything from like after
leaving the pub like she didn't remember
anything else
but another woman that was attacked and
lived did remember exactly what he
looked like and
there's another thing too is that she
told the cops
that he was a local she said he had a
yorkshire accent because he talked to
her
and they were still going with the
[ __ ] tape
yeah was like a dude with a different
accent i never did tell them how they
caught them though
yeah so they saw the they saw the
license plate
and they ended up approaching the car
and talking to him they pulled him out
of the car pulled her out of the car i
guess they searched the car
he had a hammer in there and a knife
well no it wasn't in the car i said
earlier we had it hidden in a place
there right
well what he did he got out of the car
and they were questioning him right
and then he was like um oh hey i gotta
pee
and they let him run around the corner
like behind this wall
and he dumped like a knife and a hammer
over there well he'd just say
but then he got back in the car and [ __ ]
like that but then later the cop that
said
man that guy looked a lot like that he
went back there like a little bit later
like after the car
left and he went back there and found
the hammer and then they arrested he did
have a knife and a hammer yeah
he just kind of had it on him and then
like he just went and dumped it and then
like took off
right so they they put it all together
and they said that's him well [ __ ] man
had he said nothing and gotten a lawyer
and [ __ ] he could have said
that i don't know i saw that there when
i was taking a piss like and then the
lawyer would have said yeah that's a
common place to go stash to
to do the hooks
that's a common place to do the [ __ ]
hooker action and you know that's
somewhere deep in the cut
so yeah the killer was there but this
isn't him that's what they would have
done
which is why it'd be hard to get a
conviction but he spilled his guts
he wanted to get caught he must have
yeah because i feel like
they really were not close to catching
him like i said they interviewed him
nine times but they had like [ __ ] tons
of suspects like a lot of people had
been interviewed like a lot of times
so i feel like he wasn't really i don't
think he was afraid of getting caught
maybe it had just been five years and he
was kind of sick of it or he was like
he was like some pigs of guilt or
something there's no oh
i'm sorry no no but uh
girl got lucky man she almost [ __ ]
got waxed yeah they interviewed her a
little bit like from the time period
and um yeah and she he wasn't killing
prostitutes per se
it was anybody it was any woman any
woman that
that he had that he could get his hands
on you know what i mean
it was all targets of opportunity yeah
anything to do with
and like i said i think that's kind of
why because the first two victims
like i said i'm not even sure of the
first two women that were killed
i'm not really sure if they were certain
that they were prostitutes or not
um they just assumed that they were
because they were out late at night
um you know walking around by themselves
or whatever so
you know whether they'd been working as
a prostitute or something i'm not sure
if they had like confirmation of that
but whatever the case they assumed that
at least the first two victims were
prostitutes
so then they said oh we're after a
prostitute killer
and like i said that also gave you know
people like women that weren't
prostitutes that kind of maybe
made them feel safer because like well
i'm not a hooker so that it i'm not
going to get killed but then
like the i think it was the fourth or
fifth victim was just like a 16 year old
girl
that was just like walking home from
like a party or like her job or some
[ __ ] like that
and um after that i think they finally
realized that
and then one girl one woman got killed
like in her flat
yeah like she wasn't even in the street
like you know what i mean so i kind of
feel like it was just
some of them might have been prostitutes
but i feel like it was just like if
there was a woman walking around by
herself and there was nobody else around
he'd be like ooh score and he would just
go in and give a [ __ ] if she was a
prostitute well what he's gonna check
no and like i said he was just running
up behind him and hit him with a hammer
that's what he was doing
yeah zen mavericks in there talking
about
he's arguing with people about where the
military artisans and
police what you're saying maverick the
idea that
military guys like [ __ ] rangers and
seals or protectors
that's that's new military philosophy
that came out
in recent decades you go back to the 80s
and 70s and the 60s no that's not the
way it was
no depends on which generation of
soldier you're talking about
in my generation it was all cold war
stuff
and we were being trained to fight world
war iii which was going to be
cross between nuclear combat
in an apocalyptic [ __ ] uh
war in europe or something like vietnam
it was a combination of them both
and uh it had nothing to do with
protection it had to do with just like
the total
annihilation of an enemy country exactly
what it was
there was no concept of soon as soon as
they started doing all this uh world
government stuff and we're going to do
law enforcement on other countries
the first time i saw that was uh
operation
just cause our my unit wasn't selected
because we told them numb
they shooted us from windows we're gonna
[ __ ] blow the whole [ __ ] we're
gonna
already strike the entire [ __ ]
building bring them all down
together and they were like well what
about the civilians in there and we were
like well [ __ ] them
because if they're all related
if you shoot an enemy combatant the
civilian next to him as a cousin
a few weeks later they all turn against
you anyway that's exactly what happened
in mogadishu
so uh it was just depends on how you
look at it there were different
generations
that thought different ways i don't
believe in going to war with any other
country unless you're willing to just
wipe them out
if you're not willing to wipe them out
don't go to war with them
because that's eventually what happens
all this shit's going on in afghanistan
and all this [ __ ]
in the middle east the past 20 years
it's just law enforcement if you ask me
and and it it has nothing to do with
improving the american situation or the
global situation has everything to do
with the rich people
making [ __ ] tons of money and those
[ __ ] don't even live here they live
offshore
so no i don't believe in any of that
they've totally changed the [ __ ]
culture
uh to adapt to that so the
infantry infantry soldiers of the day to
me they just they just look like cops to
me
they're not even they're not even
carrying seven magazines
they don't even know how to set camp
most of them are mechanized
it's okay man that's all i'm gonna talk
about i survived
i was doing lrs d-type [ __ ] long-range
[ __ ] patrols and recon platoons
where you're out for [ __ ] 35 40 days
you never come back you're just living
out in the woods
some of it's [ __ ] arctic up in korea
and [ __ ]
but uh no it's just it now these [ __ ]
live in hotels it's just a totally
different scene now
and uh if you're an ex-ranger or ex-seal
and you're on a police force you're
[ __ ] yourself
why would you do that you're not gonna
make hardly any money
there's all kinds of private contracting
country companies they can go to and
make 150
000 a year so it's just not worth it to
be a cop if you ask me
all right good uh not with a jacket like
that you got a badass dd214
you were in special operations and
special operations during my time
that was [ __ ] impossible to get that
they didn't want any more guys
now they just create them endlessly i
see these guys on
damn youtube ex [ __ ] fifth group and
seventh group special forces
i'm looking at him and i go man that
special forces just looks like a regular
joe
they didn't really look like regular
dudes when i was in you know it was
damn near impossible to get into those
units you had to be the [ __ ] cream
cream
cream of the crop there weren't very
many of them and they were lifers they
were in for [ __ ] 20-something years
when they got out they got huge
contracts with
the security companies they never were
civilian
they you know when they got out they
just stayed doing that kind of [ __ ]
all right all right that's all i'm gonna
talk about
i don't know you said that three times
already and then i opened my mouth and
then you just kept talking anyway
so it's like that's why i just leave a
big gap because i'm like i know that's
not all he's gonna talk about
the minute i open my mouth he's gonna
start talking again
but yeah so like i said this is on
netflix at least in the us i assume it
is in the uk as well
uh but yeah it's like actually really
interesting like they asked me if i
realized there's a racket when i did
when i was in it wasn't a racket when i
was it was very different was during a
time of transit
transition now it's a [ __ ] blatant
racket
but it's just gotten worse it's just
degenerated
you know [ __ ] i thought gulf war one
was kinda
what is this why you know what why did
we actually do it that way we got we
gotta take this dude out because we're
just gonna be back here later and that's
exactly what happened
um it was about it was about [ __ ]
money
but uh but they kind of said it was
about money so it wasn't that much of a
deception
um i definitely knew mogadishu was
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was just
we we had no business going in there
operation restore hope
no no that was that was [ __ ] and it
just progressively got worse and worse
and worse
and if you ask me it's a sign of a dying
empire
[ __ ] the union's time is limited and
it was because they were doing [ __ ] like
that
all right you sure yeah i'm sure now i'm
getting out yet
[Laughter]
but yeah i was going to say this was
actually really interesting because
like i said even though i knew a lot
about the case i like that it provided
so much of the social context
i like that they had that they did it
actually in
a chronological fashion so you could
actually follow the investigation like
sort of in real time
rather than them just saying oh this is
peter sutcliffe this is the guy that did
it
blah blah blah talking about his past
and then they go back and talk about it
i like that they did it like
as though you were living through it and
the time period you know what i mean
just over like a four hour
time so i thought that was like really
cool and like i said they came up with
even though i knew a lot about the case
they come up with came up with a bunch
of like little details and [ __ ] that i
didn't
know about like i liked seeing all the
archival footage and
i and i can't remember when we did the
show about this i can't remember if we
even
knew this because i don't remember ever
reading this anywhere before
but i didn't know about those three
women that got attacked
before william mccann got killed um you
know
and had gotten hit in the head with a
hammer like in that same area and
had lived and had reported to the cops
and they didn't really do anything about
it
so that was like new information to me
also but yeah so
this is definitely if you're into true
crime it's definitely worth watching i
also like too that
because you know how i'm not [ __ ] on
like all american true crime
documentaries because a lot of them are
really good
but i think a lot of them it kind of
suffers from
like the gordon ramsay syndrome where
it's like the british version of hell's
kitchen
or not hell's kitchen but um uh kitchen
nightmares
is like way better because it's like way
more in-depth it's like a lot more chill
um whereas the american one as much as i
love it is all just kind of like yelling
and um
you know just dramatic editing and [ __ ]
like that so i like that this
ha this had that this had like a more
british like a chilled out it wasn't all
like
and like with people screaming and [ __ ]
like that um so i thought that was
refreshing all right they're asking me
about vietnam
yes vietnam was another cluster [ __ ] all
right it was
part of the [ __ ] ramifications of
world war ii
the problem the the problems all started
in world war
ii it was when
generals realized that warfare was won
by mass production it really didn't
matter
general ship didn't matter that much if
you had unlimited production
capabilities
so the generals the general staff
officers started to realize that
the best way to win a war was to have a
lot of corporate allies and huge
corporations
so they started to mimic corporations
and the united states army went from
something kind of like a napoleonic
order of dudes who played [ __ ] kind
of like these little games on boards
with little [ __ ] lead figurines and
[ __ ]
and how to be a general they went from
that to [ __ ]
being like a corporate entity so
by the time the 50s had rolled around it
was just
corporate as [ __ ] and corporations like
to make profit
you know and they organized it in a way
to where
if you were at war the machine made
money
people got people got promoted they won
medals they ended up making enough money
to [ __ ] buy houses they uh
actually would have mansions built on
post and you had generals [ __ ]
assigned to damn matches it was [ __ ]
ridiculous
so they got involved in a [ __ ] civil
war between
vietnamese the north and the south
vietnamese
and they uh they told the public it was
trying to stop communist expansion which
is [ __ ] ridiculous because
what was his name thinking
[ __ ] what was that fucker's name
uh ho chi minh ho chi minh was
had asked the united states for [ __ ]
support material support before we ever
got into the war
and they were trying to get fran or
france out of there but france did leave
and
we kind of took france place and ho chi
minh sided with [ __ ]
with the communists all right even
though there wasn't really any communist
about the ho chi minh other than their
damn
uniforms they hated the chinese we
thought that there was going to be like
a domino effect
none of that [ __ ] happened um really
what that war was about was about
rice farming really what it was about
you had a ruling class
in vietnam that was very corrupt
um they owned all the land and they had
the rice farmers
working on the land and were charging
them exorbitant amounts of money
we got involved in there they were
rebelling
against that they ended up getting
communist backing
we went in there to stop the communists
back and next thing you know
the republic of [ __ ] south vietnam is
using the us
army to kind of conduct a genocidal war
against
the vietnamese to help them run a racket
behind rice farming and [ __ ] land
ownership it was just a [ __ ]
and uh the big corporations of course
got good government contracts behind it
they made a lot of money and they were
[ __ ] developing airborne warfare with
[ __ ] choppers they were
using it like an experiment wasn't
really a war no war was ever declared
it was just a police action see that's
the [ __ ] problem
getting all these little police actions
and this way it was set up there was no
way you'd ever win it would just it
would just be a forever war
that's what you have now these four ever
wars
and man they get all that shit's got to
stop
now gulf war one
and i joined i joined during that time
it wasn't a forever war they stopped it
you know but i that
bush won i believe i believe he knew he
was going to have to get back in there
which that eventually did happen um that
9 11 thing went down and
a lot of people say that might have been
a setup i don't know i don't have any
evidence but
uh all this [ __ ] is a sign world war ii
[ __ ] up the america world war ii
[ __ ] america up permanently
all right everything is a repercussions
of that that war never really ended
it just simmered forever so that's all
i'm going to say about it
our destiny is to break up just like the
soviet union because we needed
we needed the soviet union to hold all
this [ __ ] together
it would we would have had in and it's
just the timing's bad
yeah and um yeah i ain't buying it no
more
about it yeah you done you sure yeah
okay the future is gonna be
non-state actors non-state actors
dissolving empires and breakaway
republics that's the [ __ ]
that's the future okay
you sure i'm sure also corporate warfare
corporations will fight each other every
single time you might have
nation states def nations declaring
isometric warfare asymmetric warfare
against corporations
and corporations conducting war against
each other even though it's not really
war as you know it's just a bunch of
[ __ ] sabotage
okay no i'm sure it's not
better i'm gonna let it go
i mean you realize that we're almost
we're at 48 minutes
he's getting all like he's getting all
like ranty
all right so uh we'll be back tomorrow
to do another
matinee i'll find something entertaining
to watch tonight that we can talk about
with you guys
and uh hopefully you enjoyed our bizarre
discussion sort of mostly about the
yorkshire river but then
about other things too so we'll see you
guys again tomorrow
bye